now what does the tree of the knowledge
and good and evil represent let me give
you quick nutshell trusting the Holy
Spirit to illuminate me to speak clearly
without error for the glory of the
Father Son and Holy Spirit okay why did
the Lord say Do not e the tree of
knowledge good and evil and why did God
place it there do you want me to go a
little in- depth because I'll do a
session on this trying to tread lightly
so I don't make any mistakes trusting
the spirit our teacher to guard my
tongue from error
okay let me explain what the tree of the
knowledge of Good and Evil
represent no David Goldfield because
eating of the Tree of Life meant nothing
for Allah because he can still kill you
dead because Allah has power over
everything go David Goldfield all right
God gave them choice now this is why
Calvinism sucks and it's not
biblical God has shown us from scripture
for true loving relationships to
exist persons must be able to choose
whether they want to enter that
relationship or not so you want me to go
a little deep
here why God brought me out of Calvinism
because Calvinism doesn't make sense of
scripture if you believe everything's
pre-programmed the Bible is
clear love is
reciprocal but reciprocal love will not
exist unless you can choose not to
reciprocate now follow with me Brethren
please listen carefully because I got to
go in depth and go slowly trusting the
spirit to illuminate me to help you
understand so the Lord knew if the
love between the creatures and I is to
be true and reciprocal then creatures
must be given an ability to respond to
that love or reject
it okay follow me respond to the love or
reject
it because if you were programmed to
love God without having the ability to
reject that love then it's not genuine
love because you are nothing
but robots programmed to think that
you're making a choice when in reality
you're not well couldn't God simply
create you in such a way that you're
thinking you're making a choice when in
reality you're not because you're
programmed to choose to love God and you
couldn't choose contrarily he could have
done that but then he'd be a deceiver
why let me explain why God is a god of
Truth God is faithful to his own
character so if God had done that then
God would have known he was deceiving
mankind into thinking they're making a
choice when he knew they were not making
a choice they were simply responding to
the way he designed them so God would
have been unfaithful to himself and God
would have been acting contrary to his
own nature and that's something God
cannot do because God cannot deny
himself second Timothy
2:13 so because God is faithful to
himself and faithful to he is and cannot
act contrary to his nature and cannot
Act corruptly or deceitfully he couldn't
then create you with the impression that
you're making a choice even though
you're programmed to only choose to love
him because God would know he was
deceiving you and acting contrarily to
his nature and that would mean he was
going against his character and denying
himself something that second Timothy
2113 says God cannot
do everyone want me
there you understand why God could not
have cre Creed
you in such a way where you would be
programmed into thinking you're making a
choice but he designed you that the only
choice you could make is to love him and
then leave you with the impression
you're choosing to love him because then
he'd be acting in deceit and deception
and God is faithful to his own nature
and cannot act contrarily to his own
nature and prove faithless to his own
character second Timothy 2:13